[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 tout de suite les titres de ce
jeudi 7 septembre donner des conseils
clés en main pour organiser ses futurs
événements d'entreprise objectif du
salon sky my day qui se tenait
aujourd'hui c'était à la ferme du manet
de montigny le bretonneux
retour sur cette première édition moins
de stars et une plus grande place donnée
à la scène locale tel est le nouvel
esprit du café de la plage à maurepas
la municipalité vient de redéfinir sa
politique culturelle concernant la salle
entièrement reconstruite en 2012
et puis du sport à la fin de ce journal
à cinq clubs de saint quentin en
yvelines sont engagés dimanche dans le
3ème tour de la coupe de france de
football dont trappe et magny les
hameaux
nous recevons leur président sur ce
plateau ils affrontent tous deux plus
gros que ce week end
mais avant de développer ses titres ils
sont treize 13 pompiers des yvelines à
avoir pris la direction des antilles
parti pour aller secourir les victimes
de l'ouragan irene a de classe 5 et
d'une violence jamais enregistrée parmi
les effectifs
un chien et son maître afin de prêter
main forte dans la recherche sous les
décombres et du raid mission
indéterminée temps que l'état des lieux
de la situation n'est pas fait sur place
et des renforts supplémentaires
pourraient être envoyés dans les
prochains jours un nouveau maire pour la
commune de chevreuse à néry le pallec a
été intronisé hier lors d'un conseil
municipal extraordinaire
et l'élu de 46 ans succède à claude
genot l'ancien édile est décédé des
suites d'une longue maladie le 22 août
ses obsèques se tenait la semaine
dernière un honneur mais aussi une
douleur de reprendre le mandat pour
aérer le pallec je vous propose de
l'écouter gtl soucier un ensemble d des
dossiers qui étaient gérés par claude
genot donc on va dire que techniquement
le la transition sera assez simple avec
l'impérieuse nécessité de faire au moins
aussi bien que ce qui leur est ce que
leur ai souhaité ce qu'ils avaient
imaginé
et là nécessairement c'est un poids
c'est un poids coupat
on va tenter de porter tous ensemble je
suis sûr qu'on y arrivera premier
dossier important pour aérer le pallec à
la réalisation de la maison des
associations en construction
actuellement qui était un projet
initialement lancé par claude genot
l'actualité de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
marquée aujourd'hui par l'organisation
du premier salon du tourisme d'affaires
à la ferme de bel ébat montigny le
bretonneux
le sky my day a réuni professionnels du
marché entreprises à la recherche et
d'événements en particulier reportage de
nicolas kirillovitch que ce soit une
scène de crime des animaux ou encore une
sarbacane géantes
voilà des situations et des loisirs
difficile à imaginer entre collègues
et pourtant c'est bien l'objectif de ce
premier salon du tourisme d'affaires
proposer aux entreprises des solutions
innovantes lorsqu'elles cherchent à
renforcer la cohésion de leur équipe sur
un objectif de travailler ensemble de la
cohésion fédérer les équipes on est
vraiment sur cette école à travailler
ensemble dans un but commun que ce soit
sortir d'une pièce en 90 minutes ou
alors résoudre l'énigme le meurtre qui a
été commis on essaye de trouver des
idées un petit peu plus sympathique un
simple dîner autour d'un événement
particulier
donc d'où l'idée d'animations
particulières
voilà les scènes de crime là derrière je
pense que ça peut être très sympa près
d'une cinquantaine de prestataires
étaient présents à la ferme du manet
pour répondre à une demande en pleine
croissance le tourisme d'affaires c'est
un marché de plus de 4 milliards d'euros
en ile de france avec ses seize mille
sociétés ses nombreuses installations
sportives et culturelles l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines souhaite
profiter de cette dynamique en parlant
en échangeant sur différentes sur
différents rendez vous on s'est rendu
compte que d'une part il y avait une
véritable offre que les partenaires ne
se connaissaient pas forcément donc
c'était bien de les réunir et ensuite
que les entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines était sans doute
mon deux événements mais qu'elle n'en
avait pas connaissance et le marché
semble promis à un bel avenir pour les
entreprises spécialisées du territoire
la ryder cup en 2018 est très
certainement les jeux olympiques en 2024
seront à coup sûr des porteurs
d'affaires à leur mesure
les commerçants de la haute vallée de
chevreuse bientôt payer à la racine à la
racine c'est le nom de cette monnaie
locale qui va être mise en circulation
sur le territoire du parc naturel
régional et peut-être même au-delà
reportage de mathilde de 2 min c'est
encore en euros que l'on paie ici mais
donc quelques mois la racine pourrait
prendre le relais
une nouvelle monnaie locale va voir le
jour en vallée de chevreuse l'objectif
est double elle est d'une part de
permettre les changes
mais en faisant en sorte que cet échange
profite à l'économie locale
mais c'est aussi de créer du lien c'est
aussi de de susciter le dialogue
l'échangé le partage entre les
différents personne de du local les
commerçants de dourdan villes portes du
parc naturel régional se renseigne pour
adopter la racine qui séduit par ses
valeurs éthiques
le fondement vers le côté le côté
éthique
je dois dire ça m'a un petit peu vrai
sensibiliser le fait de changer
ce fameux mode j'étais aussi déçu qu'on
passe un petit peu à l'euro jamais bien
être franc la racine le nom racines non
puis tout ce que ça peu dégagé derrière
les habitudes de clientèle le marché le
fait de redévelopper le marché local un
travail de sensibilisation qui devra
être mis en place dans toute la ville
pour installer le dispositif de la
racine il serait peut-être bien organisé
une réunion publique fin de est bien de
prendre l'avis de tous
et puis surtout d'informer parce que
c'est peut-être effectivement
intéressant ce qui va aider les
commerces centre-ville là pouvoir rester
dynamique et contribuer au à l'achat de
proximité et de toute façon une bonne
idée après il faut voir quelles sont les
modalités de d'une monnaie locale et
comment on peut être son fonctionnement
et cette mode et locales moi je suis pas
contre
l'objectif c'est que tout le monde
participe est tout le monde joue le jeu
aussi bien le consommateur que les
magasins les commerces une monnaie
fictive qui ne combat pas encore tous
les commerçants mais qui devrait voir le
jour à dourdan en mars 2018
un collectif nouveau et qui fait déjà
parler de lui dans le département le
front social 78 a été lancé en juillet
dernier à plaisir par une trentaine de
militants
ils viennent de plusieurs horizons
solidaire pardon cgt fo and play ou
encore franz insoumise pour s'opposer à
la politique du président nouvellement
élu emmanuel macron et nous recevons sur
ce plateau deux de ses membres au front
social 78 à ma droite
freddy brunel bonsoir et à ma gauche du
cou bernard guillet bonsoir
alors première question messieurs
pour ce voilà qui découvre le front
national front social 78 pardon quelles
sont ses missions
concrètement on a pas d'émission le but
du fonds social ces c'est de créer une
unité d'action face à des lois qui sont
en cours donc par ordonnance et
conscience pour deux points sur le fond
qu'on connaît tous mais sur la forme
c'est à dire passer des ordonnances en
force pendant l'été pour casser le code
du travail pour cast et le droit du
travail des salariés
c'était tout à fait inadmissible pour
des syndicalistes que nous sommes mais
également en tant que salariés et donc
au mois de juin en séance et réunit une
intersyndicale qui s'est soldée donc par
la création d'un front social yvelines
dont fait partie solidaire l'union
syndicale solidaires notamment laissant
deux syndicats voilà donc des des
militants de la cgt des militants de fo
des militants de la cnt cgt educ en
association nous avons également attaque
60,18 nord et des partis politiques
soumises
il ya bien sûr et donc notre objectif
c'est de contrer les ordonnances impulsé
donc par ce gouvernement est justement
revendiquer le code du travail le droit
donc disponible et donc qui est et qui
généralise à l'ensemble des salariés
grâce au code du travail c'est le
minimum requis qui existe est là pour le
coup ces attaques pendant cet été
c'était pas possible donc nous avons
d'ores et déjà organisé donc une
manifestation face aux médias aient fini
on va peut-être en parlait d'ailleurs
avec bernard gear est d'ailleurs vous
parlez d'annoncer impulser de
de mesures impulsées ce même des mesures
qui ont été annoncées par le chef du
gouvernement edouard philippe juste une
question il le disait votre frère fredy
brunel c'était une évidence de créer ce
front social 60 18 face à la politique
du coup des manuels un coup aux annonces
qui ont été faites par emmanuel macron
et et son premier ministre edouard
philippe
pour nous c'est une évidence parce que
c'est pas uniquement et un
problématiques propres à chaque syndicat
ce un problème
un problème qui concerne l'ensemble des
salariés et donc il nous paraissait
important sur les yvelines justement de
se mobiliser par rapport au fait que ces
projets qui sont contenus dans l'eau la
macro en fait été élaboré par le medef
et nous avons profité l'opportunité de
l'université d'été du medef la semaine
dernière la semaine dernière il a joué
en josas it sur le campus des choses
voilà est-ce donc c'était une
mobilisation qui intègre hâtivement
forte qui était un succès nous avons
profité de cette mobilisation justement
pour mettre en évidence tout le lien
entre le programme que défend
aujourd'hui le premier ministre et le
programme aussi finalement du medef
quand on regarde les deux on s'aperçoit
que c'est exactement le programme du
medef qui est appliquée alors vous étiez
une trentaine de militants au début a
lancé ce collectif front social 78
est-ce que ça a évolué depuis est ce que
vous êtes
le nombre de minutes ont augmenté il
augmente naturellement
en fait on a travaillé tout l'été pardon
dans une idée d'un travail pédagogique
excusez moi du terme c'est souvent
relayée par le pouvoir pour essayer de
caser des orientations qui sont pas
favorables aux salariés mais nous avons
diffusé un tract qui expliquait en
grandes lignes les dangers un donc de
ces ordonnances tout en sachant qu'il
faut savoir une chose c'est que les
ordonnances qui sont appliquées et qui
qui sont en cours donc de d'application
c'est une continuité de différentes lois
qui ont cassé le droit des salariés
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années et le
gouvernement précédent est responsable
également de cette casse notamment par
différentes lois joue les nomme un la
loire rebsamen entre autres la loi elle
conneries que tout le monde connaît mais
aussi
celle que je pense qu'il faudra répéter
régulièrement c'est la loire macron 1
qui remet en cause donc les repos
notamment donc le soir et de manière
hebdomadaire
donc ça remonte à loin les buffalos
macron c'est également une casse d'une
part entière donc de garantie pour les
serveurs harry en terme donc de repos du
soir de repos hebdomadaire est donc le
fait que vous veniez de différents
syndicats différents partis politiques
est ce que aussi c'est une force pour
pour ce collectif
oui c'est une force puisque ça apporte
la richesse finalement de chaque horizon
c'est à dire que on a à la fois des
syndicats finalement que des personnes
qui travaillent dans des grosses
sociétés qu'ils soient des sociétés
d'ingénierie comme par exemple bon
cherono mais on peut aussi à guyancourt
pour le centre les yvelines voilà tu as
manqué comme très concerné par tous les
contrats précaires maintenant qu'ils
sont qui vont s'offrir à de nombreux
cadres et on a aussi des gens qui
viennent des transports
2 d'autres syndicats et
on a finalement un champ d'horizon
relativement large qui fait une unité de
vue sur le sujet dernière chose
messieurs on a parlé de cette
mobilisation la semaine dernière à
l'occasion des universités du d'été du
medef quelles sont les prochaines
actions vous allez mener alors la
prochaine action nous c'est de réussir
notamment l'action nationale donc tout
75 investi 14 heures qui est un appel
unitaire donc rejoint par et faut donc
d'autant plus important qu'ils cette
unité d'action deux syndicats j'aimerais
dire un mot quand même je suis souvent
sur cette ordonnance ces ordonnances
c'est quand on parle de l'invention
l'inversion de l'art est archi des
normes c'est la possibilité pour les
entreprises de déroger au droit des
salariés dans chaque entreprise en
termes alors c'est simple de pose de
congé de temps de travail de conditions
de travail
également deux salaires et ça il faut
absolument le refuser on ne peut pas
accepter qu'on ait des droits en revue à
la baisse un espèce de doping social
entreprise par entreprise et qui
reposerait sur un principe qui ne
seraient plus on devra le dialogue
social mais bel et bien le chantage au
sein d'entreprises et bien merci
messieurs freddy brunel et à bernard
gear est d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes membre du front
social 78 un collectif qui a été créée
donc juste avant à l'été plus d'écho
pour la scène locale axe fort de la
nouvelle politique culturelle du café de
la plage à maurepas la salle yvelinoise
reconstruite en 2012 elle n'accueillera
désormais plus de tête d'affiche mais
fera la promotion des artistes locaux
raison avancée par la municipalité une
baisse de la fréquentation du café de la
plage
le point avec mélanie poquet un café de
la plage redéfinit est consacrée aux
groupes locaux
pour cette saison la ville de mort pas à
changer sa politique culturelle
une des raisons un manque d'attrait du
public probablement une saison pas très
attirante peu de place au café de la
plage donc
beaucoup de groupes ne sont pas
intéressés par ces petites et petites
zones et puis nous ça nous coûte très
très cher
les coûts sont très importants les
entrées ont beaucoup diminué
finalement assez peu de mort passe bien
au café de la plage donc il fallait qu
on réoriente notre politique ce qui
était compliqué si vous voulez c'est que
on avait un budget programmation environ
20000 euros en 2016
35000 euros en
2010 est donc une augmentation de 15
mille euros pour le café de la plage
grâce au fonds de concours de saint
quentin en yvelines
malgré sept
cette augmentation de
de dotations sur la programmation on n'a
pas vu des faits se faire sentir sur le
public
le café accueillera aussi des
expositions les têtes d'affiché elles
seront reçues à l'espace albert camus
d'une plus grande capacité d'accueil une
décision découverte pendant l'été par
l'opposition certains élus y voit une
structure vidé de sa substance
d'autres comme michel chat pas un
désintérêt pour la jeunesse je n'ai pas
connaissance qui ait eu un travail de
commission pour réfléchir à ces
questions là comme d'habitude sous
couvert de mutualisation sous couvert
dans réorientation de fait l'activité du
café de la plage est terminée une
fermeture démentie par la majorité
municipale la saison culturelle de mort
par reprend le 23 septembre
fini le faire-part en papier place
maintenant aux jeux vidéo c'est le
concept de deux yvelinois installée dans
la pépinière d'entreprises promo paul à
montigny le bretonneux
il développe actuellement le projet je
dis oui la sortie est prévue pour cet
automne découverte en images de camille
lambert le jeu
julie et thomas vous invitent à leur
mariage mais c'est à vous de gagner les
informations lieu de la cérémonie ou
horaires du cocktail des surprises à
débloquer dans un jeu vidéo en tant que
personnes qui habitent en tant que hôte
j'envoie avait invité se faire par
vieille belge à facebook via sms
c'est un jeu en ligne qui est
personnalisé à mon image 85% des jeunes
jouent aux jeux vidéo mais 66 % et + 35
ans et plus forte progression ces les
seniors dans tout le monde peut utiliser
le jeu vidéo attrape moi si tu peux et
le premier jeu d'une longue série
une aventure rendu possible grâce à une
opération de crowdfunding elle aura
permis de récolter plus de 6000 euros
anniversaire crémaillère naissance ou
départ à la retraite je dis oui
proposera différentes versions en
fonction des événements on trouvera une
multitude de jeux on pourra choisir son
jeu
et en fonction de l'invitation et en
fonction de qui on veut l'envoyer sur
pour entreprise ou particulier au niveau
du design en fait aujourd'hui répartis
en effet sur un peu un peu vintage mais
on a un chantier ouvert sur les autres
looks à l'avenir prix de ce carton
d'invitation deux points 0,59 euro
le premier je termine sa phase de test
il faudra encore patienter jusqu'à cet
automne
deux ans qu'on ne pouvait plus le
visiter le château de rambouillet
ouvrira à nouveau ses portes au public
pour les journées du patrimoine le 16 et
17 septembre il avait fermé en 2015 pour
des travaux de rénovation extérieure re
découverte et c'est une nouvelle fois
avec camille lambert
[Musique]
c'est ici que les plus grands noms de
l'histoire de france venait se reposer
au coeur de la forêt de rambouillet de
françois 1er à louis saez et marie
antoinette ou encore le général de
gaulle cette résidence a traversé les
siècles depuis le moyen âge des années
qui commençait à peser sur l'édifice
on avait des fuites et puis certaines
parties d'enduit
s'enlevait l'isolation des salles a été
très mauvaise parce que les menuiseries
date du xviiie siècle pour la plupart
donc on a entamé cette campagne de
restauration en 2015 en restaurant
entièrement le clos et le couvert
on sait d'ailleurs de la charpente en
comprenant la toiture les menuiseries et
les façades
tout a été entièrement restauré pendant
deux ans à qui ont donc a nécessité la
fermeture du château pendant cette
période coût du chantier plus 2,5
millions d'euros
des travaux qui touchent à leur fin
quelques installations à l'intérieur
préparent la réouverture du 15 septembre
le public pourra re découvrir la grande
variété des pièces du château comme ses
boiseries rocaille du xviiie siècles
considérés comme les mieux conservés en
france aujourd'hui où les chiffres de la
comtesse de toulouse un coup on est chez
napoléon un coût mais chez le comte de
toulouse
un coup on est dans l'appartement des
chefs d'état étrangers que tu as des
appartements d'époques différentes qui
se succèdent justement ça invite
vraiment le visiteur à faire un voyage à
travers le temps un voyage avec une
exposition du 15 septembre au 22 janvier
sur la famille bourbon toulouse
penthièvre propriétaire du château au
xviiie siècle pour les journées du
patrimoine de nombreuses animations
seront proposées aux visiteurs
elle fait rêver tous les amoureux de
football la coupe de france revient ce
week end alors avant de voir des
exploits de petit poucet l'imminent des
clubs professionnels il ya le troisième
tour au programme ce week end et donc
plusieurs clubs du département seront en
lice dont 5 de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
voisins le bretonneux se déplace à
villetaneuse plaisir accueil colombienne
montigny le bretonneux accueille le may
foot enfin trappe et magny les hameaux
reçoivent respectivement le racing club
de france et le blanc mesnil
elle nous recevons d'ailleurs sur ce
plateau ces deux
club ces deux derniers club yvelinois
donc il ya un an à gauche abderrezak
guessoum bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'étoile sportive de trappes et deux
invités à ma droite françois habert
bonsoir président de manille 78 fc
également farid gagné bonsoir soit
d'être le coach donc de l'équipe
première qui sera sur les terrains ce
dimanche face à au blanc-mesnil alors
petit tour de table messieurs on va
commencer avec vous farid quatre
divisions d'écart entre entre trappe
abderrezak pardon entre trappe et le rcf
est ce que comme en voilà comment vous
allez aborder cette rencontre
il ya quatre divisions d'écart entre les
deux clubs on va l'aborder comme on a
l'habitude de faire donc c'est pas une
première on a déjà rencontrés en coupe
de france le racing club et qu'on a
qu'on a sorti aux tirs au but
il me semble que ces dernières donc pour
nous c'est pas une nouveauté la coupe de
france reste pour moi et pour les
joueurs un moment festif une compétition
supplémentaire
et puis voilà on prend
tour après tour
les rencontres si on passait ben c'est
encore un moment joyeux et festif pour
le club alors quatre divisions entre
trappe et le rcf huit divisions entre
mme annie 78 et blanc et blanc mesnil du
côté weya de manille comment comment
vous l'abordez cette rencontre peut-être
le coffre un mot dans votre farid 8
division 2 les corps il faut être
réaliste on
leblanc mini c'est un club qui joue en
nationale 3 nous on est en 4ème division
je repars avec un groupe tout neuf en
plus ce dimanche on essaiera surtout de
se faire plaisir de résister le plus
longtemps possible essayer de les faire
douter de leur montrer ce que l'on est
capable de faire même en quatrième
division district françois finalement
c'est déjà le bonheur d'être arrivé à ce
troisième tour le premier tour c'était
avant l'été un deuxième tour a joué au
mois d'août si je dis pas de bêtises et
donc la ccc 3e 3e trouve en été c'est
avant l'été les deux tours avant l'été
et du coup on arrive à ce troisième tour
je pense qu'on est déjà heureux de
figurer parmi les parmi les lots de
jouer le 3e tour surtout quand une
nationale 3 donc on va se faire plaisir
quand même nationale 3 qui est l'ex cfa
cfa2 voilà c'est ça qui sied donc le le
troisième le cinquième niveau national
voilà c'est ça qu'on ne dise pas de
bêtises pour de téléspectateurs on
rappelle peut-être comment vous en êtes
arrivés là quelle équipe vous avez eu à
affronter aux deux premiers tours
alors nous c'est notre premier
vous rentrez dedans on a rencontré une
équipe fin juin mais qui était en une
division en dessous d'accord une
division de district dont le match s'est
bien passé donc là c'est notre deuxième
match de coupe de feu n'ont évolué que
nouvelle journal régional
vous entrez après les autres équipes
elles un coup vous avez eu à jouer deux
matches avant joué contre deux équipes
du 91 qui était au dessus de nous donc
on une fois domicile d'une fois à
l'extérieur on a gagné les dommages donc
c'est qu'on se retrouve au troisième
tour et on on verra ce qui est on aurait
espéré faire l'épopée qu'on a connu il
ya trois ans calais jusqu'au quatrième
tour et chercher les maillots mais ça
sera pas le cas stan et on verra et en
plus alors si on parle du côté de près
la préparation vous avez repris
j'imagine après le blanc mesnil blanc
mesnil qui a déjà repris même son
championnat pour le district ça sera la
semaine prochaine
donc oui on se dit aussi différence de
niveau peut-être différence de forme
également tout à fait c'est également le
cas pour trappe
on a débuté dès que le 16 août la
préparation et on a déjà entamé notre
premier match de championnat
en r4 donc on a gagné contre le gobelin
dimanche dernier donc nous déjà engagé à
entamer un peu la compétition donc les
joueurs sont déjà un peu près pareil les
organismes sont déjà après ça fait du à
au moins trois semaines qui sont déjà
bien préparé donc voilà on va on va
entamer ce match de coupe de france avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé 2 on va essayer
de réussir quoique on a l'habitude de
faire
or deux dernières choses commencent à se
prépare finalement est ce qu'il ya une
préparation plus particulière par
rapport à d'autres matches à des matchs
de championnat est-ce que voilà il ya
des choses différentes pour la coupe de
france non moi je le prends comme un
match leproux comme un macho c'est pas
il n'y a pas de quelque chose de
particulier à préparer et vous farid'o
et vos joueurs vous les avez préparé
différemment parce que l'objectif il
reste le championnat et la montée en
division au dessus
je leur ai juste inculquer le plaisir de
jouer contre une équipe de ce niveau et
je pense qu'ils vont faire plaisir
alors on imagine c'est cette expérience
ça peut aussi servir pour le championnat
pour faire une belle saison derrière
même si on ne va pas plus loin au delà
de cela de ce troisième tour
complètement parce que ça reste les
matches de coupe de france comme je le
dis c'est pour les joueurs ça reste
quand même un match supplémentaire
un match de préparation un match pour en
même temps c'est le plaisir aussi
plaisir et s'évaluer par rapport à
l'équipe qu'on a en face de nous donc
c'est ça peut être un match de
préparation supplémentaire quand il
n'est pas de coupure entre le
championnat et des troubles le week-end
quoi ils sont occupés tout tous les
week-ends quoi pratiquement petit
question du côté de manille est ce qu'on
a essayé de mobiliser les manic loi pour
venir voir le match de dimanche
oui on espère qu hors du ring en
entrevue la mairie jardinage on va faire
des affiches aussi bien du camp où vous
souhaite bonne chance pour ce troisième
tour de coupe de france dont je rappelle
le nom de mes invités donc il y avait la
main gauche a des rêves adhérer zac
guessoum le président de l'étoile
sportive de trappes et donc à droite
françois berck où ça se prononce berck
donc le président de manille 78 fc et
farid gagner
le coach de l'équipe première je le
rappelle vous affronter respectivement
le racing club de france et le blanc
mesnil à dimanche pour le compte du 3e
tour de la coupe de france de football
avant de se quitter un rendez vous
traditionnel de la rentrée les forums
des associations vous permettent de vous
inscrire par exemple à des activités
culturelles ou sportives
les douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines organise le leur ce samedi est
notamment coignières dont le forum se
tient de 9h30 à 17h30 au gymnase du
moulin à vent
c'est au gymnase des droits de l'homme
pour guyancourt de 9h à 17h à la
verrière les habitants sont conviés au
gymnase de la fraternité de 10h à 17h et
de lieu à plaisir pour le forum un
plaisir de 10 heures à 17 heures le
palais des sports et le gymnase hasler
et 3 pour les clayes-sous-bois l'espace
philippe noiret l'espace sportif et le
parvis de la mairie
attention contrairement aux autres
communes le forum des associations aux
clayes-sous-bois se déroule ce dimanche
de 10h à 18h c'est la fin de ce journal
on se retrouve lundi pour le 7 8 le
journal vendredi vous retrouvez à
nicolas kirillovitch avec le 7-8 hebdo
très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]